قال وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني ديمتروكوليبا
انه سيتم ايجاد طريقه لايصال الحبوب
الاوكرانيه للاسواق العالميه اذا كانت
هناك اراده سياسيه كافيه لضمان حدوث ذلك
واكد كوليبا في تصريحات بمقر الامم
المتحده انه يمكن الاستمرار في الاطار
الحالي دون مشاركه روسيا او انشاء نموذج
جديد لايصال الحبوب
اذا كانت هناك اراده سياسيه لضمان توريد
الحبوب الاوكرانيه للاسواق العالميه فلا
بد من وجود طريقه للقيام بذلك واذا انسحبت
روسيا من المبادره فيمكن لاوكرانيا وتركيا
والامم المتحده او اي دوله في العالم ترحم
مبادره اما للاستمرار في الاطار الحالي او
انشاء نموذج جديد لايصال الحبوب المشكله
بالطبع هي ما سيحدث اذا قررت روسيا مهاجمه
سفينه تحمل حبوبا هذه هي القضيه التي ينظر
فيها الان في عواصم مختلفه وهنا في مقر
الامم المتحده ولكن ما هو واضح هو ان
الامور لا يمكن ان تبقى كما هي لا يمكننا
ان نقول فقط ان مبادره حبوب البحر الاسود
ماتت وان روسيا قتلتها علينا ايجاد بديل
وهناك مناقشات ناشطه للغايه الان